Congratulations, you
completed your first lesson.
Now we've covered a lot
of information here.
So let's just take a moment to
reflect on some of the main takeaways.
>> First,
connect your offer to the world.
To do this,
you need to understand your market.
So you can make sure you solve the right
problem to the right audience.
>> And second, I want you to focus on
the most qualitative segment first.
That way you can really show how to
light the fire and make impact quickly.
>> Third, it's good to have competitors.
It shows that someone else agrees
that there is a real need and
real market for your problem.
Just make sure you find
your unique value or
main competitive advantage you can
differentiate your product with.
>> And finally your value proposition
isn't just a useless exercise.
I can really help you connect
deeply with your product, and
know what's important when you're
pitching it to other people like
customers and investors.
So we'll see you next
time in lesson two,
when we talk about what to
do when you launch your app.